- Hello, hello.
How is everyone doing?
I realize this is day three
and the only thing keeping between you
and a happy hour is me.
So I'll try and make it interesting.
I know you have heard AI agents
all through the conference,
but trust me, this is gonna
be really interesting.
We are gonna be talking about AI agents,
the new phase of privileged
machine identities.
I'm Venu Shastri.
I'm a Senior Director of
product marketing for platform
and AI solutions at CyberArk.
And joining me for this
session is my colleague
Anat Eytan-Davidi, Senior
Manager for product management
who's leading our secure
AI agent solution.
Alright, so I don't want to assume
that everyone here knows about CyberArk.
So just a quick intro.
We are an identity security leader
that offers a comprehensive platform
for securing all types of
identities, humans, machine,
and the new wave of autonomous AI agents
all to ensure that they
have the right level
of privilege control.
Now, some of you might
recognize as a PAM leader
or privileged access management leader,
but we offer way more than that,
including things like identity
and access management,
threat detection and response, governance,
comprehensive machine
identity security and so on.
And the idea is that we
provide all these capabilities
to every identity human machine
or AI every time they're trying to access
any kind of enterprise resource.
Is it endpoint or infrastructure
or cloud to drive all
kinds of value, right?
In terms of reducing CyberArk.
In terms of cyber risk reduction,
enabling business resilience,
ensuring compliance
and increasing efficiency.
And in case you missed the news
recently Palo Alto announced
its intent to acquire CyberArk
as a part of its broader
platformization strategy.
Alright, so let's get started.
Today's focus is gonna be on agentic AI.
Right, now AI agents are
rapidly becoming the new face
of privileged machine identities
in the enterprise, right?
You have heard a lot about it.
So I'm just gonna quickly skim
through the immense potential
they have to offer,
but I'll quickly get
into why it is important
to think about the identity
security aspect of AI agents.
And then I'll have my
colleague Anat talk to you
through our secure AI agent solution
before I wrap it up with
summary and next steps.
Alright, so starting
off with the potential.
Now I know that agentic
AI is really exciting
for a lot of organizations.
It has the potential to
unlock trillions of dollars
across the industry.
This could be whether it is
software engineering, sales,
marketing, customer
operations, support and so on.
And early experiments have
shown that it's not all hype.
There is real measurable gains
that a lot of customers are getting
even as they start off on this pilot.
But what is important is that it uncovers
unprecedented risk,
especially as these AI agents
are given elevated privileges
to access enterprise resources.
Now, by definition, AI agents
means that you're giving
agency to the LLM to access and do things,
and that's where the risk is, right?
So these risks not just stem
from external threat actors,
we need to realize that we
are still in the early stages
of AI agents and they are
prone to hallucinations
or they might misunderstand the context,
so they might end up doing things
that they were not intended to do.
So further, what we need to
realize is that as agent AI
adoption grows, the
risks are gonna multiply
because the agents are going to operate
at different maturity levels.
Now, for a lot of folks,
AI agents typically means an AI assistant,
oh, I'm doing something with Copilot
and it's doing something on behalf of me.
So that's where we are today
in terms of a lot of the actual
agentic deployment in production, right?
But as you go down this chain,
it's only going to get
more and more complex.
You're gonna have organizations
that are experimenting
with completely autonomous agents
with much broader access
to enterprise resources.
These may get triggered based on,
let's say an event like
a customer support call
or a bank teller and so on, right?
And that's when you start
getting more business value,
but that's when the
risk starts increasing.
And within a year or
less, take my word for it,
you're gonna start seeing way
more complex agent systems.
You heard on the keynote today on the way
we are progressing here, right?
So that's when you have
multi-level orchestrator agents
in turn invoking other agents
and humans to do multi-step
tasks across systems, okay?
So that's when the complexity
is going to increase
the access to these
set of agents increases
and the risk goes through the roof
unless you have already these
started planning towards that.
And that's where we come in, right?
So now let's kind of
talk about the AI agents,
the fact that they're taking decisions
and they are able to reason,
the LLMs are able to reason
makes them really useful in
the enterprise context, right?
And then as we started giving
them more and more agency
to access enterprise resources
like applications, machines,
databases and so on,
a new standard has evolved.
Like Anthropic came out
with moral context protocol
and the first version of it
did not really address anything
around authentication or authorization.
Again, things are moving so fast,
we quickly realized that
that's not the way to go.
And so we are focusing a lot
on how this can be improved.
So the next version of
the standard is coming out
and we know that that is gonna
focus a lot on using OAuth
as a standard to kind of
access these resources, right?
And ensure we have a standardized way
for the agents to access those resources.
Now the other part is in terms
of what are the new risks
that come out of this.
Now, OWASP has done a
pretty good job of trying
to outline the top 10 risks, right?
And each of these risks may be targeting
a different part of the agentic system.
Some of them are targeting the components
like the applications
that they're using, right?
So for example, the agent
behavior one targets
the LLM so that it can be manipulate that
and do things like jailbreaking and so on.
Same way, agentic supply
chain targets the applications
that it does as a part of
its supply chain, right?
So there are different ways
that threat actors can use it,
but a common theme that
you see across all of this
is the fact that a lot
of them are going to use
the privileges that the agent
has on those applications.
And that's where the identity
component comes in, right?
That's where it becomes imperative.
In fact, if you heard
Swami talk about it today
in the keynote, he
specifically pointed out
that identity is becoming a
critical control plane for this.
So now let's talk about that
identity security imperative.
I'll try and make it quick
because I want to give
enough time for Anat
to get into the details.
So what we see is that AI agents
are really kind of this new identity class
that shows some characteristics
of human identity
and some of machine, right?
They're able to like reason make decisions
and they work more like
AI assistance, right?
And so a lot of immediate
focus is that AI agents
should be done like
service accounts, right?
But if you look at the autonomous agents,
that's where the agents
are behaving more like
cloud native machine workloads.
They're ephemeral in nature, right?
Traditional MFA will
not be an answer there.
You need to introduce humans in the loop
as a part of the process, right?
So overall, AI agents should be treated
as privileged machine identities, right?
Because they are, at the end of the day,
they're still machine identities.
They're highly privileged
because they have all access
to enterprise resources
and they operate at
machine scale and speed.
So our belief is that the
only way to solve this problem
of securing AI agents
is to combine these two,
securing human and machine.
Aspects of human identity,
including credential management,
zero standing privileges,
session monitoring, isolation,
and all of those as well as
securing machine identities,
which includes things like
strong authentication,
secrets rotation, certificates,
PKI, workload access,
SPIFFE and so on, right?
So we are really excited
if you have missed the news
that we will be announcing
the general availability
of CyberArk's Secure AI agent solution
by the end of the year.
Now the vision is to extend the same set
of privilege control that we do for humans
and machines to the world of AI agents.
Now our solution is built to address
all the top concerns that CISOs bring up.
Do I already have agents
running in my organization?
That's a discovery and context fees.
How can I ensure AI agents
are operating securely,
that's securing access
and enforcing zero standing privileges?
How can I quickly respond if
my AI agent is going rogue
or has gotten compromised?
That's threat detection and response.
And how can I govern AI
agents to ensure compliance,
that's governance and lifecycle.
So our solution covers
all of these aspects.
Now I realize that this
is a lightning session,
so we are not going to
have time for all of this.
So I'm gonna get my colleague Anat
to get a little more details
into the secure access part.
The quick shout out I wanted to have here
is because you heard about AWS Bedrock.
So in fact that is one of
the target agent ecosystems
for our discovery and context.
So that gives you a way
to kinda start utilizing
the solution in combination
with AWS Bedrock.
Over to you Anat.
- Perfect.
Thank you so much Venu.
And indeed, we are going
to review the solution
and we are going to focus
on the secure access piece
and how we can ensure that we can secure
the AI agent access.
So let's start by understanding
what it actually means
to secure an AI agent.
So first of all, we need to control
what the AI agent can do,
and more importantly, what the
AI agent shouldn't be doing.
Now there are cases, the bad attacker
or even the AI agent itself can bypass
those controls and guardrails.
So we also want to ensure
that the AI agent cannot
do any unintended action.
And the third challenge is,
and from talking with a lot of customers,
they see that as their first challenge
as well is how we can
monitor, how we can audit
who did what when working with AI agents.
So before diving into the solution,
let's understand what is the complexity
that we see when a granting
an access to an AI agent.
So we have an example of an
AI agent, a reporting agent
that can be used by different
persona in the organization,
HR, marketing, finance, sales, and so on.
That reporting agent can have access
to different databases
within the organization.
But we want to make sure
that as an HR employee,
I can access only my HR databases.
As a finance employee,
only my finance databases.
And as a finance manager, I
might have different permissions
on my finance database.
And on top of that, even
as a finance manager,
if my AI engine is trying
to attempt some risky
or sensitive action, I want
to provide the approval
for that access.
So whenever we are looking
at the access of the agent,
we need to understand that
we have the same agent,
different users, different
intents of what that agent
might be doing,
and therefore we need to
grant different access.
So as Venu mentioned,
AI agent identity is privileged
identity by definition.
It has access to the
most sensitive resources
in the organization.
Our SaaS applications, the
database where we store
our customer's data,
our environment where we
run our solution, okay?
So as an identity we need to treat them
as a privileged identities.
And again, AI identity
at the end of the day
is a combination of a machine identity
that behaves like a human.
That's the reason that we need
to take the controls from both identities
and combine them into a single solution
that actually addresses
the unique characteristics
of an AI agent.
And with that, I'm happy to share
that we are introducing
CyberArk AI Agent gateway.
Our gateway is an enforcement
point between the AI agent
and the tools and the targets
that AI agent can access.
With the AI agent gateway,
we can actually control the access,
we can ensure to have human
in the loop whenever needed.
We also ensure that we have
least privileged permissions
and we will talk why it is so important
to control on the permissions,
to control the permissions.
And lastly, we will be able to provide
audit and traceability.
So let's talk about the access.
So the traditional access controls
and policies that we have
in place are too static
for the dynamic and the
complex nature of AI agent.
We need to move to a
different access policy
and access controls for AI agents.
It needs to take into
consideration different factors
such as the user that
is using the AI agent,
the AI agent itself,
the risk, the context of
the request and much more.
So that's the reason
that we are introducing
a dynamic context aware
policy to address the access
and to control what are the actions
and what are the tools
that AI agent can do
or shouldn't be doing when
accessing their target resources.
So this is the first piece.
So let's now talk what happened
and how we can prevent
any unintended action.
So again, as mentioned,
AI agent identities have access
to the most sensitive environments
and targets in the organization.
Now, we already know that
excessive permissions
is a huge problem both
for human and machine,
but we are not going to talk about that
in the session right now.
But because of those excessive permissions
and taking into consideration
the way that AI agents works,
just imagine what will happen
if the AI agent identity
is being compromised or the
underlying human identity
is being compromised with
those excessive permissions,
the damage can scale immediately.
We can run thousands of
privileged permissions
in minutes and not in days
because AI agent operates
at the machine speed.
That's the reason that we need
to control the permissions
an AI agent has.
We need to ensure they always operate
under the principle of least privilege.
The permissions are granted just-in-time
only when needed and revoked
afterward in order to ensure
that we don't have any
excessive permissions
that someone can abuse.
Already today we have a
solution for least privilege
and just-in-time access for
AI agents with our MCP server,
which is available in AWS Marketplace.
So let's move to the last target
or the last, sorry, challenge.
So we actually want to restore visibility
because again, the current audit trail
that we have today are not
sufficient for the AI domain.
We need to understand
if we have an AI agent
operating on behalf of the user
who actually ran the action on the target,
is it me as an add, or it's my AI agent
that worked on behalf of me?
What was the actions that
were run on behalf of the user
or as an autonomous AI agent?
And most importantly why, okay?
So with our AI agents
sitting in the middle
between the agent and the tools,
we are able to restore
that visibility again.
So before wrapping up,
I do want to share something
with our AI agent builders.
So we know that there
is a common practice,
it is not a best practice
where developers are
actually loading API keys
and secrets into environment variables.
And that introduces
several security risks.
Among them is memory exposure
and unintended leakage
because the information is available
in those environment
variable and we are exposing
a very sensitive information
using those environments.
That's the reason that we are very happy
to share our open source
security toolkit with you.
With that security toolkit,
you are able to reduce the risk
and integrate the toolkit
with your AI agent without code changes,
ensuring that the credentials are injected
just-in-time, remove by when
they are not needed anymore.
And we are integrating
with the most common
security stores like AWS Secrets Manager,
and CyberArk Conjur.
So this is available
already today at GitHub
and I'm inviting you to
use it in order to reduce
the risk that we already have today.
So with that let's summarize.
- Sure, thank you Anat.
So I hope that you've all
found this session helpful.
Again, just a quick takeaway, right?
The fact is that AI agents
are here to stay, right?
And you need to start thinking about
securing those agents today
while the numbers are still manageable
and most of those agents are still not
fully in production, right?
So you need to start thinking about
securing these agents today, right?
The fact is that these are
gonna open up new attack vectors
and as the number of agents increase
and as the scope of access increases
because these agents get mature,
it's gonna be harder and
harder to control them.
So the time to think about
securing those agents is today.
The way to do that is
using identity security
as your foundation, right?
You ensure that these agents from get go
have least privilege.
You are putting in
tight privilege control.
You're having just-in-time access
and just enough access
so that you are able
to keep the attack surface minimal.
Alright, so what's next?
Now our solution is gonna
be generally available
the end of this month, so feel
free to swing by our booth
if you want more details about it
or you wanna talk to
one of our specialists.
We also have some
interesting white papers.
We had done an interesting
study with McKinsey
to look at how organizations
are really adopting agentic AI
and what are the type of
risk is surfacing, right?
And it talks about why
identity is the foundation
for the defense against
these agents, right?
So do download that white paper.
The other one is a white paper
that talks a more technical one,
which talks about the key requirements
to securely manage these identities.
So feel free to download
this or scan those QR codes.
Now if you're not the
exactly fond of reading
and you are itching to try something,
then we have some cool developer tools.
Anat had said about why it is
really important to shift left
and start having those best practices
as a part of building your agents, right?
So here are the QR codes for
a couple of interesting tools.
The CyberArk MCP server
for our secure cloud access
as well as CyberArk Agent Guard.
Both are available in the
AWS Marketplace to download.
So you can try them out.
Thank you for your time again.
I hope you enjoy the
rest of this conference.
We will be around to take any questions.
Thank you.
- Thank you.